as community pharmacists  we are confronted with medicine  shortages every day which have a very  negative impact on our patients  and also in our activities and at our  pharmacies we try to do our best in  order to  ensure continuity of care and minimize  this impact on our patients health  but something can also be done at  european level we believe  that eu should play a more prominent  role defining and coordinating some  policies  that could improve the prevention and  management  of medicine shortages across member  states we therefore welcome  european commission efforts to address  this issue  on the eu pharmaceutical strategy and we  really hope  that this can bring meaningful solutions  to patients and healthcare professionals  across europe  thank you very much